All Android apps must be digitally
signed before they can be installed on
a device.
The actual cryptography in math
of how the signing process works
is utterly fascinating, but also kind
of beyond the scope of this course.
Digitally signing an app
accomplishes two things.
First, it allows Google and
users who download the app to
verify the identity of
the developer that published it.
Second, it guarantees that the app
hasn't been tampered with since
it was signed.
Quite simply, signing is required for
apps on the Play Store, so
that users can be sure that the app they
are downloading was indeed published by
the listed developer.
It also protects you,
as the developer, so
that no one else can publish
an app under your name.
Gradle automatically
signs debug applications
with a special debug key that allows our
app to installed on development devices.
However, app sign with a debug key can't
be published through the Play Store.
In order to sign an app,
we first need to generate a key.
This key will be unique to you and
should be used to sign all of your apps.
We will also create a key store which
is just a special type of database
that we keep our key in.
Android Studio makes creating key stores
and generating keys incredibly simple.
Let's take a look at how this is done.